so Sean Hannity's in the middle of
another boycott we will discuss how to
fight it
Plus ROI more guilty or innocent we will
go through all of the details in
president trump sends the best tweet of
his career Bar None I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show so every week is
an adventure around here I mean really
an adventure and if you were wondering
yes I still have my cold that's why I
sound so deep-voiced and masculine today
but in any case there's so much to
discuss I want to talk about a New York
Times column which is one of the worst
columns I have ever seen in which the
author a professor at U Shiva University
suggests that his black child should not
be allowed to play with white children
no I am not kidding we'll go through the
keurig boycott there are a lot of people
who are breaking their Keurig coffee
machines and I'll explain why to you
plus we'll look at the latest on the Roy
Moore accusations breaking news the
Gloria Allred the famed gadfly and media
hound is is supposed to show up in about
two hours here and make some
announcements she's supposed to have a
press conference I guess in which she
announces that there is a second accuser
who says that when she was underage Roy
Moore the Senate Republican kanzen
Alabama sexually assaulted her
we'll discuss all this in just a second
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over a legacy box so I think
that one of the most important things
that you can do especially as you get
older is ensure that your family
memories are preserved there's
particularly true for your parents you
know your parents are getting older
they've got boxes and boxes of crap in
their garage all the old photos all the
old reels all these things you'll never
be able to watch because they're not
even on VHS tapes let alone on DVD well
what you need to do is go over to legacy
box they send you a box in the mail you
take all of these items you pack them up
you send it back to them and legacy box
puts them all together and they send it
back to you on a DVD or a thumb drive so
all of those family memories are no
longer in these waterlogged boxes in
your in your infested garage instead
they're in your house
and you can take them out take a look at
them whenever you want and when there's
a fire you just grab the thumb drive
instead of trying to schlep 37 pounds of
photos on your back out of the out of
the family garage so that's what legacy
box is for so legacy boxes comp will
slash spending at a 40% discount on your
order 250,000 families have used them
and they take care of everything that
provided updates at every step of the
way so you know that they've got your
materials they put individualized
barcodes
every one of your items you can trace it
all the way through the process again
it's legacy box comm slash bed you get a
40% discount on your order
that's legacy box comm slash bed legacy
box.com slash bed and make sure they use
that slash bed so you get the discount
and also so that they know that we say
you really as a fantastic if great
christmas gift great Hanukkah gifts if
you're trying to figure out what to get
for mom and dad nothing better than
preserving the family memories okay so
we begin today with the Keurig boycott
so this is going crazy online I want to
talk a little bit about the tactic of it
and why I think sometimes it is useful
so we have to begin with an interview
that Roy Moore did with Sean Hannity so
Sean Hannity I think has been a probably
the strongest Donald Trump defender in
the media he's also been a big Roy Moore
defender however when these allegations
arose against Roy Moore Sean Hannity
went through them and Media Matters
basically decided that they were going
to target Hannity now Media Matters is a
left-wing agitprop group run by david
brock they've targeted rush limbaugh
before they've targeted sean hannity
before they've targeted virtually every
major right-wing host has been targeted
at some point by media matters and media
matters is a clinton agitprop
organization they were they were
co-founded essentially by the Clintons
in the Podesta's and their entire goal
was to defend the Democratic agenda from
the outside what they do is they in some
cases take quotes out of context or make
up allegations or then they call up all
the advertisers on programs like Sean
Hannity and then they convince them that
there are tons of people who are super
outraged at these advertisers for
advertising on hannity and they get them
to pull their advertisements so what
they allege is a couple of things they
said that sean hannity had said that it
was consensual the the allegations about
roy board that this for that he had
taken a 14 year old girl out they'd
taken her from her home that he'd
stripped her down that he touched her
and had made her touch him they said
that that had and he had said that was
consensual had he never said any such
thing we went through that tape last
week if you recall then they said that
his interview with Roy Moore was
basically propaganda for Roy Moore it
certainly wasn't here's some clips from
the interview with Roy boy this wall you
should remember these clips cuz these
will also become relevant while we
discuss the actual allegations against
Roy board the Senate Republican
candidate Alabama
that's time in your life let me ask you
this you do remember these girls would
it be unusual for you as a 32 year old
guy to have dated
woman as young as 17 I'll be a 15 year
difference or a girl 18 do you remember
dating girls that young at that time not
generally no if I did you know just 15
things but I don't remember anything
like that but you don't specifically
remember having any girlfriend that was
in her late teens even at that time I
don't remember that and I don't remember
ever dating any girl without the
permission of her mother and I think in
their statement she said that her mother
actually encouraged her to go out with
me these allegations are completely
false false and misleading but more than
that it hurts me personally because you
know I'm a father I have one daughter I
have five granddaughters and I have a
special concern for protection of young
ladies okay so more you know these those
not good responses buy more but it was
pretty good interviewing my handy handy
went through each of the charges
individually he discussed them at length
with write more it was a good interview
it doesn't matter media matters decide
they're gonna target Sean anyway so they
go after Carrick by having my
astroturfing a bunch of people to tweet
at Kerrigan Caragh responds with this
tweet so Keurig responds by saying
Angela Angela carosone is the is the
head of media matters is good afternoon
and Keurig you're currently sponsoring
Sean Hannity's show he defends child
molester Roy Moore and attacks women who
speak out against sexual harassment
please reconsider okay he can't name how
Sean actually defended child molester
Roy Moore and he also can't explain
exactly how Sean attacked women who
spoke out against sexual harassment like
he doesn't actually have any evidence of
that this is all nonsense but Keurig
responds because advertisers get afraid
of controversy so Keurig responds by
saying Angelou thank you for your
concern and for bringing this to our
attention we worked with our media
partner and Fox News to stop our ad from
airing during the sean hannity show so
they pulled their advertisements well
this drove a lot of Sean's fans to
basically pull a reverse boycott and say
okay we're not gonna buy accurate
products anymore if you're gonna pull
stuff based on Media Matters going after
Sean Hannity well then we're not gonna
sponsor you right you won't sponsor Sean
we won't sponsor you now there are a
couple of things that are right about
this and maybe one thing that I think is
a problem but here are some video of
people destroying their Keurig machines
so this is this one is going viral this
is a fellow who decide to go golfing
against his Keurig machine he tweeted
guys magnet Twitter is drilling current
machines with 10-pound practice drivers
here we go
and there goes the Keurig machine I
believe we have one here at the office
we have not yet shattered it the reason
we haven't shattered it yet is because
if you shatter a machine that you
already bought that doesn't actually
involve a boycott right like if I
shatter something I've already bought
all that means is that I don't have the
thing anymore so I'm not really sure how
that is effective but the idea that
you're gonna boycott a place like Keurig
for pulling out advertising it's not
completely wrongheaded I think that a
lot of people who are making fun of it
today this is not the only example of
somebody to strung a Keurig machine
here's another example of somebody doing
it wait oh boy the second story somebody
broke the Keurig machine again I don't
see the point of buying a product and
then breaking the product that doesn't
make a lot of sense to me if you want to
boycott here just don't buy more k-cups
but here is sort of the logic when I was
at Ruth revolt we launched boycott
campaigns against people like Al
Sharpton against Martin Bashir on MSNBC
when we launched a boycott campaign
against Alec Baldwin we helped get Alec
Baldwin kicked off the air at MSNBC the
point of those was not because we
thought the boycotting advertisers that
sponsor programs politically is wrong in
fact we obviously love that the reason
we did that is because we were trying to
prove to the left that this is a bad
tactic we wanted mutually assured
destruction the idea here is that
whenever the left gets angry they
pressure advertisers to pull advertising
from political programming and that's
really dangerous because what that ends
up doing is creating a market vacuum
where people refuse to advertise on
places like Fox News you want know why
Fox News is constantly running you know
catheter ads and why MSNBC which has
lower ratings is constantly running car
ads the reason is because nobody is
boycotting the cars but a lot of people
are boycotting new cars if they appear
in Fox News so long as the left insists
on playing this game playing the game in
Reverse seems to me justified as a
mutually assured destruction scenario it
shouldn't be something that we embrace
wholeheartedly it shouldn't be something
where we say yeah boycott advertisers I
don't like boycotting advertisers I
think that it's generally wrong but if
the idea here is that you have to teach
advertisers number one that you can
astroturf a call on pretty much anything
and number two teach to the left that
this takes it this has the same effect
on the left that it has on the right and
everybody should you know put down their
guns and that seems to me like that'd be
a worthwhile thing meet at the bottom
line here's the Media Matters a really
despicable organisation and they're
making
allegations in order to go after Sean
you know there are plenty of things that
Media Matters could go after Sean after
if they wanted to but that's not exactly
what they decided to do instead they
decided to take Sean out of context
deliberately in order to go after him
and it's pathetic that advertisers fell
prey to that speaking of taking out of
context there's an article in Time
magazine today that I just want to
correct
Time magazine around an allegation by a
girl who was 16 I guess when she met
George HW Bush HW was 79 at the time and
apparently HW grabbed this girl's ass
apparently he this is the allegation
anyway is that HW grabbed this woman's
butt and she was shocked by it here's
the piece from from Time magazine her
name I guess is Rosalyn Corrigan now in
say hydras links apparently she's a
listener of the show the reason I know
that she's a listener of the show is
because it says in the article she said
recently she was listening to an episode
of a podcast hosted by ben shapiro
called his everything sexual assault
that was a couple weeks ago allegations
against bush were discussed on the show
and she said when i heard that was the
reason like oh he's just an old man and
he doesn't know any better and he's just
being harmless and playful and it's just
where his arm falls i just burst into
uncontrollable sobbing Corrigan said I
just couldn't sit with that I can't I
can't sit with that I can't sleep
anymore because that's not true and it's
not an excuse well I thought what I said
on the show and I actually don't think
that's what Corrigan is saying I to give
her credit I really don't think that
this this particular lady is saying that
I said on the show that HW Bush did it
because he was senile when I said on the
show is if he did it because it was Cena
because he's actually senile that's a
different story than if he did it not
being senile in which case he deserves
to be punched right if somebody grabbed
my wife's ass I would punch them at the
very least I'd push them around a little
bit okay the idea that it's okay if you
are not senile but you're old is just
ridiculous the idea that old guys can do
this stuff I said it on the show two
weeks ago right you can go back and
listen to the show but Time magazine
reports that out of context as though I
was defending bush and saying he was see
now I wasn't saying that at all I was
saying if he's seen how that changes the
scenario but if he's not senile then
that's obviously disgusting behavior
I've been I you know not to not to toot
my own horn here but I've been pretty
damn consistent on the sexual harassment
frontier and pretty consistent on the
sexual assault sexual harassment front
and that's why I'm trying to you know on
the Roy Moore stuff be as objective as
possible so today one of the things that
I want to do here is go through the what
I think are five have various
perspectives that are all
together with regard to the Roy Moore
allegations the latest on the Roy Moore
allegations as I say is the Gloria
Allred is saying that she wants to
present another accuser who's underage
and Roy Moore sexually assaulted her
that's the that's the the accusation
apparently according to the mainstream
media and there is the Breitbart news
also was going out of its way they're
sending a couple of different reporters
down to Alabama to try and discredit the
the story about the fourteen-year-old
girl who is who has accused now she's
you know in her fifties who accused
right more of taking her home and then
sexually assaulting her essentially so
here are the five perspectives on the
Roy Moore sadness he listened to the
audio already ok listen to the audio
more I don't find it particularly a
compelling defense saying I always talk
to her mother's first is not really an
excuse for dating underage girls the the
idea that when he says I can't remember
dating some of these women and then he
says well there was one of these women
and I remember being friends with her if
you want to call it a date I guess it's
a date
none of this speaks well to to his
recollection of events he was very
careful in that interview to say he'd
done nothing illegal but he did not
really deny knowledge of anything except
this 14-year old girl now the reason the
fourteen-year-old girl her allegations
are credible is because there are
supporting details that are credible
right so she says that she met him in
court that more basically recruited her
outside a courtroom her mom was in the
court but Roy Moore said I'll wait out
here with a fourteen-year-old daughter
and then he started hitting on her and
got her phone number and all of this
more was at the court at the time she
was at the court at the time her mom was
at the court at the time there are
multiple witnesses who say that this
woman has told the story over and over
and then she was sought out by The
Washington Post right she wasn't looking
for glory she wasn't looking for a
settlement she wasn't looking for cash
instead the Washington Post had to
basically push her into testifying now
the way that Breitbart pushes that
Breitbart news has pushed this in the
sense that well look at the Washington
Post they're politically motivated right
we know they're politically motivated
that's true that doesn't mean the
underlying facts are not true it's
politically motivated when Andrew
Breitbart goes after Andrew Weiner I
know I know Andrew you know that that's
it but that doesn't mean that what he
was saying was false and I think we have
to separate these things out politically
motivated does not always mean false
okay so here are the five perspectives I
think on a more and what to do about him
so perspective number one is turnabout
is fair play there are a lot of people
in
other right who are looking around
they're saying listen the left is not
willing to throw anyone out no matter
what the standard we can't play we can't
disarm ourselves right this is the
prisoner's dilemma I was talking about
last week I don't think it's necessarily
a moral perspective but it's a
politically advantageous one I guess
this is the idea that the left is not
gonna throw out people like bob menendez
so why we throw out roy more without
natural conviction and you were actually
convicted the Democrats are not gonna
throw out bob menendez right dick durbin
the senator from Illinois was asked
about Bob Menendez who is currently on
trial for corruption the senator from
New Jersey and he's asked if he's
convicted will you will you move to kick
him out of the Senate Durbin won't even
answer the question if your colleague
Senator Bob Menendez new jersey democrat
is convicted on the corruption charges
he's on trial right now the jury is
still deliberating will you vote to
expel him I'm not going to get into the
hypotheticals on either of these
situations as I said several steps
removed I'm hopeful that when all is
said and done that Bob Menendez will be
returning to the Senate representing the
state of New Jersey okay so this idea
that the Democrats are somehow moral
players here is obviously not true and a
lot of Republicans are responding to
this by basically saying well fine if
you're not gonna get rid of it ed knows
why would you get rid of more right Amy
Klobuchar who's the the Democrat senator
from Minnesota
she says that maybe if if Moore is
elected maybe will expel him but I don't
remember her saying anything like this
grabbin Edna's who's actually on trial
right now you're in favor of starting
the expulsion process potentially if he
is elected that's one way we can do it
but the other way is for the people of
Alabama to look at these two candidates
and yes I have faith that they're gonna
look at what happened in these
allegations and the fact that there's 30
witnesses and make a decision on someone
else again oh the hypocrisy front
lawrence O'Donnell who's not said one
word as far as I'm aware about expelling
Bob Menendez he asks Mitch McConnell he
says what are you gonna do about more
what are you gonna do about more and a
lot of people out there like well screw
you you won't do anything about your own
people why should we do anything about
our people again I'm not saying this is
a moral perspective and I'm gonna play
my own perspective further but I think
that it's worthwhile elucidate in the
various perspectives before I go any
further here I first want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at my Patriot
supply so you seen a lot of natural
disasters on the news lately is he
natural disaster in California in Texas
and Florida and Puerto Rico you see
natural disasters a big earthquake
yesterday in the Middle East when the
stuff happens it should be
reminder that natural disasters can't
happen there may be a time where you
can't actually get to the grocery store
but you're out of supplies the
government can't get to you for a couple
of days that's why you need my Patriot
supply the government recommends that
you have a certain amount of food on
hand in case bad things happen that's
what my Patriot supply is for get the
100 is serving a survival food kit for
just 99 bucks it includes breakfast
lunches and dinners that you shipped to
your home for free or a kit for yourself
right now call eight eight eight eight
oh three fourteen thirteen or go online
to prepare with bed comm again that's
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen or go online to
prepare with Ben comm eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen prepare
with Ben calm people at the office have
tried it they say it tastes like Hubbell
cooking at last twenty five years in
storage so for 99 bucks you're basically
making your family save for the next
twenty five years he was a pretty good
deal to me okay so here is lawrence
O'Donnell and ripping on Mitch McConnell
and say what are you gonna do about the
right war meanwhile the entire
Democratic Party continues to pretend
that Bob Menendez doesn't exist if these
allegations are true and how will Mitch
McConnell decide if they are true will
he question Roy Moore about it he has
the power to do that will he bring Roy
Moore right back to Washington to sit
with his potential future Republican
colleagues and allow those colleagues to
question him about this again this is
this office pressure from the left it
makes a lot of people on the right we
can stop it there what makes a lot of
people on the right feel as though this
is a political partisan hit job and then
if the situation were reversed they
would be defending their Democrats which
probably is true right Jeffrey Goldberg
says the Washington Post is neutral on
more Jeffrey Goldberg is the editor of
the Atlantic that's obviously laughable
the Washington Post is not neutral on
more their editorial board endorsed his
opponents in Alabama so obviously they
have some feelings on the issue now does
that mean that the allegations are not
credible or the reporting is bad no it
doesn't but when people keep insisting
that the Washington Post has no agenda
with regard to the election two things
can be true ones they can have an agenda
and the allegations can be true but
people seem to be able to take only one
perspective if they have an agenda that
means the allegations are false or the
allegations are true and they have no
agenda here's Jeffrey Goldberg saying
that Washington Post has no agenda which
obviously is not true so on the one hand
we do have an intolerance for this
across different fields and industries
on the other hand you could still
succeed in America pretty pretty easily
with with some really nasty stuff in
your back
well especially if you believe that the
other side is making this stuff up or
doing it only for partisan reasons I
mean this is why so many people are
sticking with the party because they
believe that the other side is lying
about what really trying to cast the
Washington Post is awful research in the
Washington Post direction
okay this idea when you have all these
media people who hate Trump hate more
sitting around going we're neutral
arbiters no wonder so many people are
reacting this way there's a poll out
today showing that 37% of evangelicals
said that they're more likely to vote
for Roy Moore in the aftermath of the
allegations that's not because they
actually believe you raped a
fourteen-year-old or tried to write
that's believed that that's because they
believe that the media is out to get it
right it's that simple that's obviously
what's going on here so that this
perspective I think has become the
default perspective for a lot of
Republicans and a lot of Democrats
because the next time there's a Bill
Clinton character who goes around
sexually assaulting women Democrats are
gonna say well you guys were fine with
Trump and more that's the way this is
gonna go and it has been going this way
for the last 20 years I think that Trump
and more just the culmination of that
effect right here's Chuck Todd Chuck
Todd says did did Trump get a pass from
voters because of Bill Clinton's
behavior well the answer is sort of yes
right I mean that I think there's some
truth to that what do you say to voters
who say boy all these people that were
upset about Donald Trump they weren't
upset about Bill Clinton do you think
that one of the reasons why Donald Trump
got a pass from voters is because of
what happened in the 90s to Bill Clinton
okay the answer to that question is
obviously asked we don't need her answer
the answer that question is obviously
yes this has become the predominant
perspective so perspective number one
not one I think is particularly moral
but it certainly is prevalent is
turnabout is fair play if nobody's gonna
have any standards on this why should we
okay perspective number two is I think
maybe the most honest and also the most
immoral perspective this is the david
horowitz perspective which is okay so he
busted a fourteen-year-old girl who
cares
seriously this is actually david
horowitz perspective he tweeted out in
my view more as guilty as accused but
one it happened 30 years ago which um so
- he can't be removed from the ballot
again um so and three this is the one
that matters to him electing a
demonstrations a party that defends
these criminals Obama the Clintons
holder Lynch Abbot and Cheryl Mills etc
and their crimes are far far worse right
so this is the binary perspective that
literally Donald Trump could have shot
someone on Fifth Avenue really like
literally done it and David Horne would
sort of
important him because he doesn't want
Hillary Clinton to be President so this
does raise a question that we're all
gonna have to deal with what are you
willing to accept in a candidate to
defeat the other side if you believe the
other side is so deeply evil that every
seat is worth electing a child molester
then we may as well kiss goodbye to any
standards for our candidates at all
right because some of our candidates
will probably be good people but some of
them may be absolute crap fests and to
be honest this seems like again a very
common perspective that no one actually
wants to articulate all right this seems
almost like the underlying perspective
for a lot of people who say the
turnabout is fair play there are certain
number of them a subset who say who
cares okay fine let's say he did it the
other side still worse there's still
worse still worse is a very good excuse
for you embracing something really
really bad this was one of the logic
that I that I found utterly non
compelling and actually quite
off-putting during the last election
cycle it exists on the Left however the
left still maintains that JFK is some
sort of Halcyon of decency and Wonder
right JFK his Camelot here's what we
know about JFK right they know that
there was a woman named Mimi Alford who
was an intern at the White House she was
18 when she started there she wrote a
book called Once Upon a secret my affair
with President John F Kennedy and it's
aftermath she was at the White House in
turn a 19 year old rising sophomore at
Wheaton College and JFK used her as
basically a drug mule and apparently as
a as a I mean that's basically her
her her allegation according to the New
Republic her story's entirely believable
she was an attractive naive recent
graduate of Miss Porter's school Miss
Porter's was also the element matter of
Jackie Kennedy and it was slightly older
White House secretary named Fidel
with whom Hannity was also having an
affair and apparently he was also
dealing with fiddles close friend
Faneuil a secretary in the press office
I mean JFK was just a scumbag
apparently he led Mimi into his wife's
bedroom unbuttoned her blouse touched
her breasts pulled down her underwear
dropped his pants climbed on top of her
and had sex with her Wendy too when she
told him she was a virgin he became more
compassionate but in neither in that
sexual encounter nor any other did he
kiss her on the lips and then there was
one incident where there was a guy named
Dave powers who worked for who worked
for Kennedy who's sitting poolside while
the president and I swam lazy circles
around each other splashing playfully
remember she's 19 JFK the split he's in
his 40s ready to the allegations about
more that he was 33 and the girl was 16
or 17 or 18
except for the 14 year old which didn't
allegation David removed his jacket and
loosened his tie and the warm air of the
pool but he was otherwise fully clothed
he was sitting on a towel with his pants
leg rolled up in his bare feet dangling
in the water the president swam over and
whispered in my ear mr. powers looks a
little tense would you take care of it
it was a dare but I knew exactly what he
meant this was a challenge to give Dave
powers oral sex and then Jeff came
basically manipulated this young girl
into the into doing this right and then
the left still celebrates him so there's
a group of people on the left you say
the same thing well JFK was better than
his opposition is better than then
tricky dick Nixon
so who cares okay I'll give you another
example of the who cares phenomenon
Harvey Milk
considered a hero by many on the Left my
Harvey Milk is considered just a
wonderful wonderful man a hero a sexual
hero okay Harvey Milk statutorily raped
a 16 year old boy okay the guy that
guy's name was John Galen McKinley and
he was 16 years old and milk who was
then 33 right very similar to the
allegations began living with with this
kid the 16 year old kid they moved into
Harvey Milk's Upper West Side apartment
according to biographer by Randy Shilts
says they brought a dog named trick a
Catholic called trade and settled into a
middle-class domestic marriage at 33
milk was launching a new life that could
hardly have imagined the unlikely
direction toward which his new lover
would pull him okay his lover at this
age was sixteen years old does the left
have anything to say about that again
the answer is no because who cares
Harvey Milk was a hero and so we have to
bury all of this stuff right we can't
imagine the people our multi-faceted and
so we have to bury all of this stuff so
the perspective number one is the other
side does it so who cares I think that's
wrong
then I'll explain why in a minute I
think that's wrong I've really explained
it already a little bit which is just
because the other side is it doesn't
mean it's moral for you to do it if the
other side is electing a bunch of
murderers that doesn't mean it's moral
for you to elect a bunch of murderers to
fight them number two is the other side
is so evil that we have to do everything
possible to stop them including siding
with terrible people that shows very
little faith in humanity
it also shows very little faith in God
really that God always has to use the
most imperfect vessel and it really
shows little faith in human beings
because the fact is that Roy Moore if he
dropped out today there'd be a writing
campaign for Luther strange or for or
for mo Brooks and that person would
likely win the seat right now the polls
show that more is down about four points
to the Democratic challenger in freaking
Alabama okay perspective number three
is one that I'm hearing a lot it's sort
of a legalistic perspective that I think
is really just again a facet of the
first to the other side does it and who
cares and that is he wasn't convicted in
a court of law
I'm hearing this a lot I know that
there's a guy on my name Jacob wall and
he's been saying he wasn't convicted in
a court of law that's true you know who
else was not convicted in a court of law
Hillary Clinton right Hodor Clint was
not convicted in a court of law of
anything and yet we treated her as a
criminal because she was committing
criminal activities no matter what James
Comey said and we didn't vote her into
the office of the White House because of
that right so the bottom line is that
you know in your own mind you don't get
to beg off just because the person
wasn't convicted unless this is a
consistent rule you uphold if you're
consistent rule is I will vote for
anyone so long as they weren't convicted
then you'd vote for OJ Simpson for
higher office so long as you voted the
right way on abortion okay but
acknowledge that this is what you're
doing in the reality is that's not how
people vote that's not true so all I'm
asking for people is that they uphold a
consistent standard if your standard is
you don't care because the other side
does it or if your standard is you don't
care because the other side is so evil
or if your standard is the person has to
be legally convicted in order for me to
care then at least uphold that standard
on all sides but you don't get to pick
and choose which people are gonna use
the new standard for Senator Tim Scott I
think has this exactly right he says
listen in the end it is not the the
judge that's gonna be the judge it's
gonna be the voters who are the judge
just said they were with Hillary Clinton
in this case though if the allegations
are true he's denying them how do you
how do you find proof there's no doubt
that the case is compelling the judge
and the jury in this case will be the
people of Alabama the voters of Alabama
they will have an opportunity to weigh
in very clearly and decisively and very
shortly but this current situation will
have to be solved by the people of
Alabama and the voters will be the judge
in the jury okay so that being the case
this brings up the final two
perspectives and these are the ones that
I think are really the most interesting
and honest these are the ones that I
think matter the most okay the first
perspective you those in one second
these are the perspectives that matter
the most but before then I first want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
stamps.com so you don't want to go to
the post office in wait in line you just
don't okay you may love the post office
maybe your favorite place you don't have
time for that you have work to do
that's why you need to go over stamps
comp we use it here at the office
stamps.com
allows you to print out postage directly
your office and print it directly under
the envelope you can print it onto a
sticker you can print it onto a piece of
paper and tape it to the on
they will give you a digital scale so
that you don't have to worry about what
kind of postage you're using if it's the
right amount of postage and if it's
gonna come back to you
stamps.com is everything that you need
from the post office acceptance right
here at your office they bring all the
amazing services of the Postal Service
to your fingertips again by print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail we use stamps
that come to the office because we run a
tight ship and if you run a tight ship
you should as well right now you can
enjoy the stamps comm service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
it's pretty awesome deal just go to
stamps comm and there's a microphone at
the top of the page and type in Shapiro
that stamps comm and then enter that
promo code Shapiro and that means that
you'll get a four week trial plus
postage and the digital scale which is
pretty great right you get all those
things and you never have to go to the
post office again again that's stamps
comm promo code Shapiro there's a reason
that we use it here at Daily wire okay
so finally the last two perspective so
the first three perspectives all have
something in common they're basically
saying he could have done it and I'm
still not sure that I would do anything
about it right that then there is the
perspective of the people who believe
that this sort of thing makes a
difference right who believe that if he
actually did it then he should not be
running for Senate and we should not
elect him to the Senate and this brings
up where I think most people actually
are right I think most people actually
are here okay let me rephrase most
people may be in the first category but
they like to think they're in this
category right most people may be in the
category where they don't really care
whether more didn't they just want to
know whether he's gonna be a senator
they like but more most people want to
believe in their heart they are is that
it would make a difference if a guy but
less than a fourteen-year-old in their
vote okay so this breaks down into two
categories
Morris the allegations against more
credible the allegations against more or
not so well we've been hearing
consistently from Republicans if this is
true he should step down the problem is
there's no ability to prove it's true
because it's a he-said she-said she-said
situation which means that you have to
use your brain and determine whether you
think the allegations are credible and
I'm not gonna decide that for you
I happen to think the allegations are
credible I think they're credible
because there multiple witnesses who are
contemporaneous who back up the accounts
because there they were there to see the
thing but she apparently told them about
it at the time it's credible because
apparently according to a former ta who
worked with more it was common knowledge
used to hang out at the high school and
pick up chicks okay all of this seems
credible to me but you can certainly
make the case it's not particularly
credible
can make that case so Pat to me the
senator from Pennsylvania he's saying
that he's saying you know I'm not sure I
find these allegations particularly
credible again you can hold this
perspective for sure and what you may
think is that this is a political hit
job it's an apple research piece that's
not well substantiated designed to take
out more and so the motivation combines
with the lack of credibility of the
story to mean that it's all BS okay so
here's Pat Toomey sort of making that
case look I've said I don't find the
denial terribly credible but when
someone waits forty years before they
make an accusation you know that raises
a question itself so it's probably not
knowable but there seems to be enough
enough there that it's very disturbing
okay so you know again it's not credible
it's not knowable waiting 40 years
raises questions waiting many years to
talk about this stuff as I discussed
last week really is not the key issue oh
really if you know women who have been
sexually assaulted many of them never
reported it but they'll tell you about
it and the reason they didn't report it
is because they were 14 or 15 and they
felt they felt a drift and they felt
like they may have been guilty they felt
like the cops weren't gonna listen to
them they felt like people were going to
attach that that sort of stigma to them
the rest of their lives and they'd
rather hide it and try and try and deal
with it themselves not rare in the
slightest they're people trying to call
the question the credibility of the
count I think the bottom line is you're
either gonna have to believe the woman
who says that she was assaulted when she
was 14 or you're not going to because
Breitbart has been trying to take this
apart and they're doing a terrible job
of it so Breitbart
obviously is very invested in this
particular race because Steve Bannon
wanted to claim credit for his primary
woodmoor's primary what even though he
really had nothing to do with it but
he's tied himself to Moore's leg and so
now he's assigned to reporters one of
them actually is the Jerusalem bureau
chief Aaron Klein who's done a good
amount of good reporting in Middle East
but hasn't done much here there's a
piece here saying I like Aaron but this
is not a particularly revelatory report
this was the lead at Breitbart yesterday
exclusive mother of Roy Moore accused
her contradicts key detail of daughters
sexual misconduct story that sounds
pretty damning right it sounds like the
story is falling apart right the key
detail is falling apart here's the key
detail this is direct quote from the
story Kaufman the woman's name is Leigh
Kaufman clearly claimed she spoke to
more on what she said was her phone in
her bedroom at least one of those
occasion
the post did not specify whether the
second or third alleged calls
purportedly took place on a bedroom
phone wells corphals mother was asked by
Breitbart news back then did she have
her own fool phone in her room or
something no she replied
matter-of-factly but the phone in the
house could eat could get through to her
easily and then it says the Post story
relies heavily on Kaufman's memory and
her ability to recount events
consistently is that a real
inconsistency that that she would send
she was talking on her phone in her
bedroom okay first of all it's possible
that the Washington Post should put a
comma after her phone comma in her
bedroom second of all I know that all
the young kids today don't remember like
actual phones with wires attached to
them but every person who remembers a
phone attached to a wire remembers
taking a phone and stretching it all the
way to their bedroom every single person
okay if you ever look at the old phones
that have cords on them all of the cords
are stretched out of recognition right
they have the curly cords you know and
they're all curled like a pigtail
you know if you pull if you go look go
look it and you'll go to your grandma's
house look at the phone that has on the
wall that cord the cord is stretched out
of recognition it's all it's all messed
up the reason it's messed up is because
kids take the phone and they pull it all
the way in their room and then they talk
there if this is bright Bart's great
hope to discredit the story that's weak
T here's another Breitbart headline weak
tea more weak tea from Breitbart and
then the headline was exclusive mother
of Roy Moore accuser Washington Post
reporters convinced my daughter to go
public now if they really think that
that's actually a slap against the
credibility of the woman it's precisely
the reverse right if you if you are a
publicity and you were looking to
get into the papers by giving a false
allegation when you be seeking out the
Washington Post I mean this is what
reporters do reporters call up people
and try to convince them to go on the
record that happens on a routine basis
it's happened to be many times I've done
it several times and there's nothing
wrong with that that's how people go on
the record so again this is a bit of a
stretch again you may find that the
allegations are not credible you may
think the timing means that the
allegations are not credible I don't
quite buy that but that's that's at
least a case okay that's the case that
you're gonna make if you if you say Chao
mallow stations enough to keep you out
of the Senate you need to make the case
the limit is not credible okay finally
there's prospective five and that is
that this is credible I'll tell you who
thinks this is credible so Senate
Majority Leader McConnell said today
that he thinks it's credible the Trump
administration is saying they think it's
credible okay Kellyanne Conway is bueno
yesterday basically said she thinks it's
credible the Trump administration said
if it's true more should step down
Steve minuchin the Treasury Secretary
who's a Lackey for Trump here's what he
had to say about it yesterday I'm not an
expert on this issue but what I would
say is people should investigate this
issue and get the facts and if these
allegations are true absolutely this is
incredibly inappropriate behavior do you
believe the allegations again I just
watch what I see on TV I know but you
have an opinion do you believe it it
appears that there is a significant
issue here that needs to be addressed
okay so that's that's basically his way
of saying yes they're credible so the
reason that I'm spending so much time on
this is because I think that we all need
to his moral human beings as people who
are trying to do the right thing I think
we need to examine in our own minds what
our standards are so we know for the
future like let's be honest about our
own standards here it's the dishonesty
that bothers me not actually your
standard your standard may bother me but
you're distant but the dishonesty
bothers me more my standard is people
who abuse sexually abused children at 14
or about whom there are credible
allegations should not be sitting in the
Senate right that's my standard
and then I determined that I think these
allegations are credible or not I tend
to think that they're credible at least
according to what I've seen so far then
their people say they're not credible
okay
again if that's what you come up with if
you think that these are not credible
allegations explain why and maybe we can
have a conversation about that then
there are the other perspectives one it
doesn't matter because the other side is
so terrible if you think that we
shouldn't live in a country with other
people who are Decorah called Democrats
you should actually go to war with them
if you believe that people are so evil
that in order to fight them you need to
elect child molesters to the Senate then
I would suggest that we ought to be in a
state of open war rather than pretending
that we live in an innocent in the same
country
then there's the perspective that the
other side does it so it's okay for me
this is a way that you have a race to
the bottom on politics I talked about
this last week
I object to the the prisoner's dilemma
logic because prisoner's dilemma does
not carry a moral burden right that's
just a question of game theory but when
it carries a moral burden there is a
moral burden to you when you say oh I
care more about losing the Senate seat
in Alabama than electing an alleged
child molester that's a right that I
think that's immoral as well and then
there's the the final perspective which
is that he wasn't convicted by a jury if
that's been your consistent standard
fine if it hasn't been then just
recognize that you're full of it okay
time for the I want to talk about the
greatest tweet the trump has ever sent
so here is in
the greatest tweet that Trump has ever
sent it's one of the reason that Trump
supporters love him his approval ratings
back up to 46% this demonstrates every
time Trump goes abroad and he can't stay
at home eliminating about domestic
issues and bothering everyone everyone
likes him when he's overseas and he his
reactions hey everyone his approval
rating has had 46% right now that's the
highest it's been in a long time the
reason is because he's overseas and he's
kind of slapping people around overseas
and we sort of like that so apparently
kim jeong-hoon called trump old so trump
so Trump responded this way this is the
greatest single tweet of my lifetime
it's so good he said why would Kim why
would kim jeong-hoon insult me by
calling me old when I would never call
him short and fat oh well I try so hard
to be his friend and maybe someday that
will happen spectacular spectacular peak
Trump okay I got to admit like there are
a bunch of people who are getting all
exercised about this I love it I think
it's hilarious
I get rolling kim jungeun okay maybe go
i'll tie a nuclear hell fowler of
hellfire tomorrow possible you know the
history books will read World War 3
began when a Twitter storm ran out of
control and kim jong hoon fired a
nuclear-tipped missile at California
based on Donald J Trump calling me short
in fact I don't think that's what's
gonna happen so who cares I think it's
hilarious it's really my girl they
haven't sent the humor people that's
some funny stuff okay so I want to talk
a little bit about Trump abroad that was
the good of Trump abroad and then I want
to talk about some the other things he
said plus this horrible column from the
New York Times but first you're gonna
have to go over and subscribe it's a Lee
Weyer comm for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe at daily wired.com when you do
you get the rest of my show live on
video you got the rest of Michael
Mosley's show live on video get the rest
of the Andrew Clavin show live on video
get to be part of my mailbag and you
also get to be part of the mailbag on
the conversation so the next episode of
the conversation is happening tomorrow
Tuesday November 14th 5:00 p.m. Eastern
2 p.m. Pacific featuring Michael Mills
god help us Michael's conversation will
stream live on The Daily wire website
Facebook page and YouTube channel it'll
be free for everyone to watch but only
subscribers can ask the questions that's
why you should subscribe subscribe today
and ask Michael questions and join the
conversation
tomorrow and you can watch it no matter
what but you can only ask questions if
you're a subscriber if you get the
annual subscription instead of $9.99 a
month it is $99 a year and it which is
actually cheaper and it comes with this
the one most wonderful vessel for
beverage drinking ever created the
leftist here's
hot or cold mug currently filled with
soothing tea and let me tell you it
holds tea like no other vessel it is
just spectacular so go over and check
that out if you want to listen later
please subscribe to our channel over at
YouTube go over to iTunes and SoundCloud
subscribe there leave us a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
okay so Trump abroad sends that tweet
which I again I think it's just it is a
spectacular tweet I mean that is a 10
out of 10 for Trump and then he sent
some other things that were not so great
he continues to make weird noises about
Russia about how he wants to be best
friends with Putin I here is what he
said about getting along with Russia now
at the same time I want to be able
because I think it's very important to
get along with Russia to get along with
China to get along with Vietnam to get
along with lots of countries because we
have a lot of things we have to sell and
frankly Russia and China in particular
can help us with the North Korea problem
which is one of our truly great problems
so I'm not looking to stand and start
arguing with somebody when this report
is all around and cameras recording and
seeing our conversation I think was very
obvious to everybody I believe that
President Putin really feels and he
feels strongly that he did not meddle in
our election okay so who cares if he
feels strongly that in meddle in the
election like what difference does that
make a lot of people were upset with
Trump for saying this again this is
typical Trump but the reason people on
the right aren't so upset is because on
the other side of the national security
aisle are a bunch of people on the Left
who pretended that Russia was no threat
at all back in 2012 when Mitt Romney was
calling him the lead geopolitical front
on planet earth and Barack Obama was
saying that the 1980s called him onto
their foreign policy back John Brennan
and James clapper both of them political
hacks they were out there ripping Trump
saying well it's a badge of honor to be
called political hacks by Trump well
they are political hacks I mean James
clapper went in front of the Congress of
the United States and lied openly about
NSA programs the president also called
both of you and FBI director Comey
political hacks all three of you worked
in senior levels in the Obama
administration although you also worked
during the Bush administration how do
you respond to the charge well first of
all he was referring to us as political
hacks because he was trying to deal
jidam eyes the intelligent assessment
was done Jim clapper Jim Comey and John
Brennan did not write that assessment it
was written by the professional
intelligence officers and law
enforcement officers of this great
country secondly I feel very honored to
be associated with Jim clapper and Jim
Comey in the same category
and considering the source of the
criticism I consider that they destroyed
their own credibility and then Trump
goes after their credibility this is
their own fault if you destroy your own
credibility and then Trump goes after
your credibility even on behalf of silly
causes then that is really the fault of
these people so Trump is saying a lot of
things I disagree with on the foreign
policy front but the bottom line is so
long as he's attacking people like
clapper and and people like and people
like Brennan he's gonna get away with it
because they destroyed their credibility
long before Trump ever touch them with a
ten-foot pole
okay time for some things I like things
I hate and then we will go through a
federalist paper we go through one of
those weeks so things I like over the
weekend I got to see thor ragnarok I
loved it I thought it was love is a
little strong I strongly liked it I I
thought it was really really really
funny oh you have to go in knowing that
is just funny right hey yeah it's not
gonna be meaningful it's not gonna be
moving it's not gonna be deep you're not
gonna feel anything but you're gonna
laugh because it's really funny
Chris Hemsworth is a very talented comic
actor Mark Ruffalo is is fine I don't
think he was particularly funny but I
think that Hemsworth was whether it was
a good comic actor Tom Hiddleston who
plays Loki is a fine comic actor there
are a lot of very very funny moments and
this the best thing in it is actually a
character who was made of rocks and is
voiced by the director who's who's
really really funny as well so go in and
enjoy yourself it's a really enjoyable
film Jeff Goldblum gives a bizarre fully
Jackman he goes full-blown like there is
no half Goldblum he goes full Goldblum
in this one and it's very enjoyable
here's a little of the preview
so much has happened since I last saw
you
I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh
and then I went on a journey of
self-discovery
that you
[Music]
where are we you have no idea
hello the goddess of death is invaded as
the movie basically has no plot
okay the plot of the movie is almost
irrelevant what's funny is all the jokes
and it starts right off the top I mean
the very first five minutes of the
method has a very very funny visual
sight gag that's very funny
go and enjoy it it's just a good time
it's not gonna be something that you sit
around contemplating at the end of days
but it is something or if you just need
a break and you need to laugh then then
it'll by the way this is my favorite
kind of Marvel movie DC movies I expect
some depth from Marvel movies I want to
be ant-man this one is a lot closer to
ant-man that it is Captain America which
is good I don't like the Captain America
movies I think they're wildly overrated
okay you know let's go straight to some
things that I hate so it is amazing how
depending on where you are political you
can get away with certain things so
George Takei went after President Trump
as you remember for the p-word tape
saying that if you're famous you can
grab women by the bleep and get away
with it here's George Takei on Howard
Stern's show being asked about sexually
assaulting men and the Fuhrer is
non-existent it doesn't exist listen to
what Takei says here all your years
involved with do you never get hassled
anybody or grabbed there anybody back up
yeah did you ever grab anyone by the
against their will you never sexually
harassed an a boner have you it's it's
some people that are kind of skittish
right Oh
or maybe afraid and you're trying to
persuade that but you know do we need to
call the police the answer is yes you do
need to call the police but Takei gets
away with it men what is Takei says he
blames the Russians he literally tweeted
out yesterday that this is only an issue
because the Russians were making an
issue out of it he said a friend sent me
this it is a chart of what Russian bots
have been doing to amplify stories
containing the allegations against me
it's clear they want to count me into
silence but do not fear friends I won't
succumb to that succumb to what first of
all there is nothing there about about
Russian BOTS people are talking about
you because you said you grabbed dudes
by the Wiener ok that's literally what
you said on Howard Stern's show in order
to encourage
that if you're a straight man doing that
to a woman you might be arrested okay
but if you're on the Left I guess you
gotta get away with this kind of
nonsense okay other things that I hate
so I mentioned there's this New York
Times column that's just astonishingly
awful it's by a professor over a civil
university Benjamin Cardozo School of
Law and this professor has written a
piece basically saying that he doesn't
want to teach his kids to be friends
with white kids
it starts off my old visit the
professor's name is ek Jenka and it says
my oldest son wrestling with
four-year-olds happy struggles is trying
to clarify how many people can be his
best friend this is my best friends are
you at mama and my brother and but even
a child's joy is not immune to this
ominous political period this summer's
images of violence in Charlottesville
Virginia prompted an array of questions
some people hate others because they are
different I offer lamely a childish but
distinct panic entered his voice but I'm
not different it is impossible to convey
the mixture of heartbreak and fear I
feel for him Donald Trump election has
made it clear that I will teach my boys
the lesson generations old one that I
for the most part nearly escaped I will
teach them to be cautious I will teach
them suspicions I will teach them to
distrust much sooner than I thought I
would I will have to discuss with my
boys whether they can truly be friends
with white people this thing it
continues for like 900 words about why
you can't if you're black person you
can't have meaningful friendships with
white people he says he wants to teach
his child to distrust white people he
says Martin Luther King's famous dream
of black and white children holding
hands was a dream precisely because he
realized that in Alabama conditions of
dominance made real friendship between
white and black people impossible well
no that's not what he said he said that
he had a dream that one day that would
be possible and this guy is fighting
against that he said I'll teach my boys
to have profound doubts that friendship
with white people as possible his direct
quote imagine the races were reversed
and think about how Richard Spencer
would write this or John C Calhoun right
he actually says I mean it's astonishing
he says I will teach my son's that
they're beautiful he was a faultline
spare me platitudes of how we are all
the same on the inside so I guess we're
not all the same on the inside I mean
this is baseline racism being run in the
op-ed page of the New York Times but
it's around the left you can get away
with it just astonishing stuff but again
I don't know if they're in a competition
to run the worst editorial of all time
every day but each day they seem to be
topping themselves over at the New York
Times editorial page okay quick note
Federalist three so we've been do this
one really quickly because this is one
of the more famous Federalist Papers
we've been going through one of the
Federalist Papers each week we did
list 1 and 2 the last couple weeks now
is Federalist 3 this one written by John
J the first Chief Justice of the United
States Supreme Court there's long before
that of course so in this in this
Federalist paper J is trying to make the
case that we should have one united
country instead of a bunch of little
countries right why we should be one
country instead of a bunch of states
that have their own foreign policy and
borders he says that we need one united
country to prevent foreign invasions he
said local governments won't be able to
follow sectional foreign policies said
because we'll have a national government
instead and he makes this point he says
it is of high importance to the peace of
America that she observed the law of
nations toward all these powers and to
me it appears evident that this will be
more perfectly and punctually done by
one national government that it could
either be done by thirteen separate
states or by three or four distinct
Confederacy's the idea big if you want
to bring war to the continent all you
have to do is have three or four
different places on the continents each
declaring war in their own good time
which of course is true and then he
makes the point he says not a single
Indian war has yet been occasioned by
aggressions of the present federal
government feeble as it is but there are
several instances of Indian hostilities
having been provoked by the improper
conduct of individual states and this is
true historically if you look at a lot
of the conflicts the Native Americans
that were not driven by the federal
government they're driven by various
state governments seeking to enlarge
their territory and mistreat Native
Americans in many cases the federal
government was called in to militate
against those states so this was the
case that John Jay was making you need a
national government because a series of
smaller governments would generate more
conflict in war that's certainly been
true throughout American history okay so
we will be back here at tomorrow with
all of the latest updates I'm speaking
at UCLA tonight I believe it's sold out
maybe we can find some tickets online
that you can find scalped or something
but it's happening tonight at 6 p.m. at
UCLA so I look forward to seeing you
there I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]